le che merci fort boyard ce sera chez
take olivier minne magloire willy
rovelli toute la bande
1 sacd harga et je te revoir la séquence
avec isa siouplaît qu'on a mise à
l'index handball va l'avoir va les faire
un gros bisou n'est pas moi c'est les
pieds de plus de 20 ans non mais je sais
c'est un temps maintenant de regarder on
peut revoir la séquence roulerait
l'armoire parce que c'est la seule qui
passe devant le bail là c'est ouais ce
fou rire alors allons pouvoir le sont
souples et lotions on veut le son à fond
la came c'est nous pas voir le sont
merci remettez au début
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
il arrive je te dis je tenais avec moi
frais année c'est un portable coup tu te
calmes c'est la première fois qu'il veut
vraiment m'appelait mon frère
[Applaudissements]
camel meriem
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est le portable de match chamakh
astana n'ont jamais je vais voir voilà
le code alors benjamin savez je suivre
je veux garder ton portable pour
l'instant il suis bien sûr tu te
comporte mal je verrai ce que j'en fais
simplement il s'est bien comporté par la
sq ont ça va moins bien la casse qui a
eu cette idée je trouverai les
responsables et je me désolidarise
complètement cette je sais j'en avais
oui chérie on s'est retrouvé dans un
instant
lorient
[Applaudissements]
hier
les séries